this is a production of Cornell
University so I'm gonna be talking about
developing a little bit about developing
multi-use naked barley for New York I'm
first going to focus on what naked
barley is of how whether its potential
uses in a future market um some of the
challenges of naked organic barley and
I'm gonna do a little bit of focus on
some results so far in terms of we
competitive ability and if there's time
I will look at show you some of the
protein and yield data from first gear
so what is naked barley on it's simply
barley without the hull and so what that
means is when barley is it's threshed on
when harvested but the hull falls off
similar fashion to wheat compare that to
malting barley with a halt remains on
the grain on some examples right here
are our Copeland and full pint eye which
are hauled barley and then buck which is
hauless or naked and which all falls off
on this gene of for Hollis barley is
characterized by the nut gene on
chromosome 7 HL it's recessive and it's
loss of function single point mutation
and so on in theory it's quite easy to
breed out of after a couple selfing
generations however there are some
modifiers which make it a little bit
more difficult to make truly naked
sometimes ah the big advantage of Hollis
barley or naked barley compared to whole
barley is that without the whole you
don't have to purl it and it could be
useful for food purposes also in order
to determine the the potential for naked
multi-use organic barley on we're kind
of basing our potential success off
these to move these two movements or
sources of increased markets the first
being the craft brewing movement on as
Dan mentioned in seminar last Tuesday
there there's been an increased movement
for using
naked malted barley uh particularly in
New York on the New York farm brewery
bill as incentivized local Brewers and
mall stirs to sorcerer ingredients from
New York on that in combined with the
organic grain market on which there's
been an increase in demand for novelty
food grains and with previous work of
value-added grains with mark Lisa and
Lisa kissing Cusack and June rustle I
have been really instrumental in
developing market for organic grains so
hopefully with the combination of the
moulting and brewing ended movement and
the organic grains we can replicate the
success with multi use organic barley so
what are the potential benefits
specifically um as I previously
mentioned the characteristic is no
hollows its main selling point health
benefits such as beta glucan and protein
levels compared to wheat on but mainly
we're really focused as an alternative
crop organic farmers and so some of
these are characteristics that we hope
that organic farmers can sell to our
moulting and if moulting doesn't work we
can do food and if food doesn't work we
can go for the feed market however
the feed market can be a bit dismal but
perhaps with organics there'll be a
better better market compared to the
conventional counterpart so um
unfortunately with naked barley there's
a lot of challenges and I'll start with
the agronomic ones of course we have to
worry about yield with barley um winter
kill for the winters and lodging and
then we worry about environmental
factors that barley is highly sensitive
to disease resistance scald and powdery
mildew for the winners our leaf rust
it's pot wash for the springs and of
course for zrm head blight for malting
in food we have worried about static
traits on is the barley going to be
marketable on for example if you have a
purple barley that's going to be
definitely more marketable than say
conventional white barley protein and
beta glucan and more specifically within
the problem protein beta glucan your
food Barley's will probably where you
might want your food Barley's that have
a higher level and moulting to have a
bit lower level and then of course in
New York we have a pre harvest sprouting
issue which was really a problem this
year where the grain germinates in the
field on so we want to avoid that in an
edition with disease resistance we want
we're concerned about the don being part
of the grain and then those are your
ganic specific challenges on with yield
you have different management are
concerning the grain on fertilizer
applications and whatnot certified
organic land what nutrients are
available for that disease resistance on
you have limited amount of fungicides
that you can use if there's some sea
borne diseases there is currently no
solution and of course we competitive
ability and so put all these traits
together um you have Cordova to consider
and so well we hope to make gains and
all these making idealized schemes and
all of these won't necessarily be
possible so for this for what I'm going
to be talking about here I'm going to be
focusing on these three traits protein
we competitive ability in yield so for
the project these are the three main
approaches we have the marketing to
market market the grain on as something
that people should buy on which is kind
of putting the cart in front of the
horse a little bit with this breeding
project education um we have a barley
composite central little local middle
school so they get to learn about of
aspects of barley on or any genetic
concepts the teacher might want I talk
to them about and then the research
component which is what I'm here for
so so I would so we have both the
diversity panel in a regional panel our
regional trials I wanted to talk about
the diversity panel however
we did get some good data on height on
heavy date disease
but due to the do the inclement weather
short amount of time and it being a
diversity panel the seed the seed
phenotypes were not that great so I'm
I'll before we talk about that for now
and then of course regional Charles on
so for the regional feel design and
management our entries included released
some release varieties including bucket
streaker that we've grown out on Ford
grow New York City already awesome
hauled checks selections from Oregon
State based on the previous diversity
panels they've conducted and breeding
efforts and some naked lines that have
been grown here for the past few years
for the field design I for these trials
we had 25 entries for the winner 20 for
the spring on each one of the three
replicates randomized complete block
design for the locations for the winners
we had one only one location at free
though and from the springs we had to
loop we had two locations for the
springs one also at free will and one at
Musgrave and I in regards to management
practices relevant for these phenotypes
we did do try and weeding on as much as
I would like as much as we might be able
to get a better read percent management
without tying weeding breeding for weed
competitive ability supposed to
complement organic practices not replace
them and of course organic fertilizer
rates are in effect yield and protein on
somewhat so for we competitive ability
attempting to find what characteristics
are related to yield they're quite
difficult on they're easily confound
with environment on things such as
previous year rotation of what crop was
there before it I'm just random factors
that result in weed to spurt weed seed
dispersal it's just a very hard for you
know type of true measure so pretty much
what I've done is trying to do like a
shotgun approach and identify certain
more flat barley traits and weed weed
measurements to see how well on if any
of them correlate to you and we can use
them I
as evidence of an entry having a higher
we competitive ability compared to
others so some of these traits that I
phenotype included stand counts and
October in November 2017 early vigor
where one is that they plants not even
there and nine plant completely fills
out the plot and May and June I did
wheat barley percentages and I measured
that by using this PVC point five meter
squared plot by throwing in rent section
and then seeing how much what percent
within that plot is either barley weeds
or neither so it would be ground and
then did that twice for each plot and
then did it for all of them and then
recorded plant form where one is
prostrate so the barley spreads out and
five is erect and recorded these values
um for the verb weed and barley plant
form three times every two weeks so
these were the weed results of the weeds
for the winter regional this bar graphs
show cases of rye
varieties that had the greatest
differentiation for weeds on
unfortunately a lot of the weed though
unfortunately there was a lot of wheats
in winter or at least they weren't on
very correlated with yield most likely
due to the dry weather conditions and or
it could be that all these barley
varieties may have some effect and we've
depression but between Barley's and
other plants I didn't we haven't grown
those yet so it would be hard to say so
these were some of the correlations for
these traits that I measured on overall
plant form and sent weeds wasn't very
highly correlated
barley not surprisingly if more barley
given in the plot it's going to have a
higher correlation Stan counts and vigor
had some correlation but on nothing too
too promising but it's important to keep
in mind this is only the first year this
is only the first year and so more we're
going to need to do this
for multiple years to get multiple
weather conditions or weather conditions
that will be more desirable for weeds to
grow and maybe not so much for barley to
see whether these wheat or barley will
truly on I will compete the wheats as in
a tree so we did the same thing for the
Springs locations free ville and free
ville and Musgrave on it we same same
traits the only thing that I did add is
that I did beat counts when I did the
wheat barley percentages as a proxy to
see well maybe if we account for the the
type of weeds or the size of the weeds
maybe that will have a greater
correlation on it recorded those three
times every two weeks as well um
unfortunately that was even worse on due
to the Sousa trout or severely localized
drought in Musgraves and the fact that
these were planted very late on May 25th
there wasn't many weeds in the first
place because even weeds don't like dry
weather lots of ground space as well
because the Barley's had a hard time
growing this environment on so
unfortunately we weren't able to get
much weed measurement data on now these
valleys of barley again are highly
correlated surprisingly so in the weed
measurements were more highly correlated
however that's really hard to say
whether it was the barley that
suppressed them or if it was more rather
they filled in the void on the barley
just not growing in the first place
I've free ville we had a little better
success a little better weed pressures
in must be over the winter location but
even then with with a drought on WE
conditions still drought the weather
conditions still impeded the growth of
weeds looking at some of these
correlations again our two highest ones
were barley and for this one it was a
vigor rating on in the future i for this
trait it'll probably be better to
measure on barley at
certain stages as a plant where these
where barley is more highly correlated
if we wanted to turn whether these can
grow faster either that or we're gonna
have to do a better job of accounting
for for the weeds and so forth at it we
would have to do more of an experiment
where we would have to like seed the
ground with a certain population of
weeds that are relevant to that stage
that that stage and development of the
barley so on so yeah so these are
questions I would hope the answer so for
overall yield performance of the winners
they did quite well this is a
statistical model used to fit on
responses yield I didn't put any fixed
effects in as any of the fixed effects
tried had no significance on Iran that
the random effect was i with entry model
was such and for the error variance well
you did it rows columns spatial
correction where the diagonals
represents the error for each plot and
the off diagonals represent the distance
correlated errors between the plots and
overall these yields did quite quite
well but on it's important to consider
that this is only the first year on a
lot of these are not specialties
selected to row malting so a lot of the
energy for the plant on can be focused
more on the grain yield as opposed to
other traits that you would select for
from malting so that may be a
contribution to why these are a bit
higher and then and then these for the
springs on the only thing that was
different is that I added a fixed effect
for location on and as expected these
did not do so Springs had a very hard
time this year with unfavorable weather
conditions and even between the dismal
conditions at Musgrave and free though
being marginally better the distribution
of these scores are still quite narrow
so the weather certainly played an
effect for that I also did protein on
took a 20 grand to
you know type protein took a 20 gram
sample from each plot samples analyzed
using a fuss and our our system on using
least squares regression and depending
if the barley was a Hollis or a halt
check
there's calibrated on separate files on
because all whole calibration files do
not help calibrate all this ones or
naked ones so for overall protein
performance on the same model use the
same models yield only with response of
protein said on overall for the winters
they did quite well in terms of our
desired range for what it should be for
proteins however this is only one year
and we'll still need to evaluate these
across better years to get a better
picture of how these will respond in
terms of protein ranges and if we have
not phenotype for beta glucan yet but
that should be another factor in
determining whether these might have
some potential mall quality i for the
springs these also didn't do well in
that regard either same model as
previous one except adding a fixed
effect location due to the do the the
weather on protein gyros tend to be much
higher and on and barley when there's
not enough water or there's a lot of
drought and so hopefully next year we'll
have a better accurate depiction of
these spring Barley's on with better
weather conditions so future plans in
terms of multi-use organic barley on
with a genomic data the diversity panel
i hope to find different hope to combine
with the phenotypes have some
temperature potential information for
some genome-wide Association studies and
perhaps examined different method
message measuring the rate of growth of
barley and with that I acknowledge ins
like thank my committee members mark
Gary and Sam alkane on the entire soils
lab group funding sources on the anak
web group in synapses
[Applause]
any questions I apologize that that was
just a journal they could barely picture
that was not germinated I apologize put
that one up there
that's it was not relevant to the
protein my post from the field on deck
directly take a pod sample from on yep
lots yep after they're harvested and
wait of course yeah so um I didn't I
didn't put that bad in here but I did
take note of which ones they were and to
account for that I did take kind of the
size on but yeah I have been taking
notes on what kind of weeds are present
so if I were to do with seeding
experiment on those of the weeds are
used on generally it's a lot of lambs
for this for the winners you have to
worry about henbit and chickweed and for
the springs you have to worry about
pigweed and land quarters more so you
mean to use a correlation for errors
between spots or was that supposed to be
an AR one there was supposed to be an
error this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at Cornell
edu